the very special special thing so I'm
really excited to be here Jennifer
Aniston is out here making 51 look
amazing and a number of her celebrity
friends took to social media to send
birthday wishes Courtney Cox posted a
photo of her
apparently wearing a wig of Aniston's
iconic Rachel haircut she wrote quote no
matter how hard you might try there's
only one Jennifer Aniston overwhelming
unbelievable
her co-star on the morning show Reese
Witherspoon said happy birthday Jen I
couldn't ask for a better friend and
partner to chase my dreams with life is
way more fun with you in it even
Aniston's ex-husband justin theroux got
in on the celebrations the actor posted
this photo to his insta story in rope
grabbing 2020 and another year just like
followed by happy birthday be it's
really special because it's my it's my
beers Aniston's 2020 is indeed off to an
amazing start
she's already picked up a SAG Award and
then there's the biggest news of all 25
years of what like since it was thought
of a friends reunion special is
reportedly being developed for HBO max
her birthday on Tuesday was also
commemorated with a stunning photo shoot
for the March issue of interview
magazine just take it route work out
take care of yourself eat well in her
profile Aniston opened up about what she
imagines for her future she revealed
quote it's not so much what I see myself
doing but it's more like a little
screenshot in my brain where I hear the
ocean I see the ocean I hear the
laughter I see the kids running I hear
ice in a glass I smell food being cooked
that's the joyous snapshot in my head
[Music]